sauf ah oui quand même
dans la foule à madonna la mange n'y a
non la frère à oued ans à simon et jo si
mamadou nous
n'en savons est unique commun est unique
au doigt mais l'acier sa fin oui sauf
que vous imaginez le dic pour les femmes
artistes aujourd'hui aux chanteuses
plein dion elle est trop mec magasin
elle est parfaite on dit jamais la même
chose demi sardou dit pas voilà là il a
pris un coup il a parlé d'un coup de
peid to ride et les to free c'est où ça
reste lourd on a dévoilé à shanghai où
il a vachement vite jamais
jamais il a toujours été là vu le
meilleur pour lui une femme une pression
permanente sur leurs visages la
résolution trois ans baptisé moi ce sont
des six ans ça c'est le jeu c'est normal
mais bon est-ce qu'il n'a jamais dit
celle qui n'a jamais fait de chirurgie
esthétique elle
serre dans le monde entier avec sa belle
pour la wii et subitement on est une
icône bref ça aurait pris on est pied on
se met à rêver on vous attend qu'ils
essaient
d'être écoutés
dur de vieillir on assure julien fau
venus depuis alors elle n'a ni nié ni
confirmé
mais un médecin de chirurgie esthétique
a dit qu'elle avait fait un plan tessier
mâchoire romoli hall b saint jo wing
paraît-il augmentation d'élèves botox
lifting du visage et quand elle a vu
tout ça dans un dom magazine elle a dit
qu'elle ne niait pas d'accord voilà très
bien c'était votre info du jour passé
pas mal quand même doit il faire une
émission people
il a il a le truc oui j'ai regardé en
fait c'est une evros canadien les fans
sont inquiets parce que il ya cette
photo là quand elle sort du restaurant
avec son fils donc là elle est épié lé
pas parader et sur instagram elle publie
les photos avec des filtres etc donc
elle assume pas vraiment ses 63 ans
c'est ça regardez les deux là c'est
incroyable perte c'est ça qui choque les
femmes et c'est là où les femmes se
disent on a perdu madonna est elle-même
solaire ne sait plus où elle en est
fière d c'est fou elle est belle à la
laine fine mais c'est la vérité est soit
la réalité des filtres away
soixante trois ans mais ça n'existe pas
58 oh oui encore trembler beaucoup au
jeune thomas dollars
sa mère mais toi tu es comme le
commandant cousteau
toujours
je les connais la lehman s'ils ont les
mêmes toutes et tous ont reconnu
j'adorais le gars il a toujours vue du
commandant cousteau quand il est à 25
ans on dirait qu'ils en avaient sous la
visière la bassée l'avait bien aussi ben
ouais mais castaldi aussi
pas mal je vous le dis hein quand vous
faites vieux depuis longtemps vous juste
vernède c'est tranquille
on dira jamais où vous avez pris un coup
de vieux merci non mais c'est vrai on
est honnête il ya quelque chose non en
oui qu'est vraiment sérieux il ya
quelques années j'ai croisé tom cruise
dans un restaurant tom chose tom cruise
aux assauts dans un restaurant j'ai eu à
coeur cruz comme sous sections sociaux
dans ce tome coudassot dans un
restaurant j'ai vu un monsieur dans la
tablette up show dans un zoo
non et j'ai vu un monsieur petit un peu
bouffi un peu ridé et en fait il n'avait
pas d'actualité ces gens là dans la vie
de tous les jours et prenne du poids et
quand un film arrive trois mois avant
ils ont allumé sioniste ils font de la
muscu à fond parfois ils prennent des
produits un peu aussi pour aider et il
faut pour devenir mission impossible
mission impossible mais dans la vraie
vie pas contient pas de film bah c'est
un mec de 60 ans cadets jouent qu'à des
rideaux garde rugby bien sûr aussi beau
petit
je m'auto graves comme ça une autre il
était sympa ton coin by the edit un
visiting funds love love you very much
et il m'a
payée à l'heure du match bahjaoui
dimitri payet a dit quoi rire il a
marqué comme bruce tant que c'était at
home et permet aux normes ce et
voilà les bovins mais mon histoire est
là là vous le voyez comme ça moi je l'aï
vu avant-hier je veux dire j'ai bien
mentir au bowling il faut juste et la
boule